welcome to CSV 141 the UN sa carrière
retribution designed with realism and
function in mind familiar layouts of
modern-day naval carriers and spacecraft
combined to create a gritty raw
environment grounded in reality and as
captain nick reyes players will take the
helm of the warship and lead its crew on
a perilous journey across our vast solar
system the retribution acts as the game
central hub where players will prep
deploy and returned from missions as the
action unfolds in real time players will
lead their ship and crew across the main
story line or on optional side missions
where additional upgrades can be earned
to help them fight enemy forces that
have attacked our world and threaten our
very way of life the retribution flight
deck is an extremely active in place
reminiscent of present-day carriers air
base crews work around the clock to
maintain and resupply aircraft launching
two and returning from combat donning
iconic naval jerseys with each color
designating a specific critical role
aboard the vessel crew members will
engage with the player directly their
interactions range from short gestures
to more instructional conversations
designed to push the narrative forward
and keep players immersed in the world
around them so we should be studying
good on Kevin thanks 18 like its crew
the retribution has a personality of its
own with a rich character arc that
unfolds throughout the progression of
the story launch and three